benjamin ouimet est une boule d'énergie
le garçon de 10 ans peine à tenir en
place mais il ya deux ans il a dû
ralentir
on en est arrivé puis comment sa boîte
et puis peut-être une journée après il
marchait plus le diagnostic est tombé
maladie de l'aig calvet perte est ce une
maladie rare qui provoque la nécrose des
vaisseaux sanguins autour de l'os
fémorale à sa hanche droite quelques
double demande est trop court et parce
que l'école voit tout le monde courir
tout ce qu'on a recommandé aux parents
de benjamin c'est de réduire ces
mouvements au minimum car clan enfants à
cette maladie qui est en douleur mais
tous de trouver une solution est
actuellement deux variétés dans cette
maladie avec seulement deux histoires
naturelles différentes qui peut arriver
il a vraiment et il est envahi par un
sentiment d'impuissance les oui mais se
sont renseignés ils ont décidé de se
tourner vers l'oxygénothérapie hyperbare
qui a été utilisé à cuba dans un
contexte similaire après seulement deux
séries de traitement l'effet se fait
sentir pour benjamin à chaque soir est
toujours mal elle n'a encore jamais
jamais bien sûr c'était celle massage à
tous les soirs tylenol adv lots ou
quatre heures mais les parents n'ont
droit à aucun remboursement
parce que ces traitements ne sont pas
reconnus par le gouvernement comme étant
efficace pour la maladie de benjamin
comme pour bien des maladies rares est
possible de connaître le nombre de
personnes atteintes
un regroupement québécois réclament
depuis des années un registre et une
meilleure prise en charge des patients
ce qu'enfin on va s'en occuper
d'ailleurs unique théâtre les maladies
comme une des maladies les autres sans
les parents de benjamin espère que les
traitements en chambre hyperbare vont
lui permettre d'éviter de subir une
chirurgie pour l'instant il semble être
sur la bonne voie et si camille
carpentier radio canada québec